JOHN STUPPY: Welcome,
everyone.
I'm glad you're here.
You guys excited for I/O?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN STUPPY: Great.
Well, let me introduce
the team.
My name is John Stuppy.
And I'm joined by Jon
Boekenoogen, my colleague on
the Google Wallet Instant Buy
team as well as Haisoo Shin,
Director of Engineering and Lead
Android Developer for The
Fancy, one of our first initial
integration partners
of Google Wallet Instant Buy.
Today we're discussing building
compelling mCommerce
experiences on Android.
So let's get started.
As you heard earlier today,
there are 900 million Android
devices in the world.
And what are people using
these devices
for more and more?
Shopping.
But it's not as easy as just
having compelling products and
services to get users to
actually convert on your
mCommerce applications.
We find three big challenges.
The first, discovery.
How do people find your
applications and products?
How do they get excited
about them?
Then, when a user likes your
application, how does she tell
you a little bit more about
herself and sign up for your
application so that you can then
tell her about upcoming
product promotions
and other offers?
And finally, when she finds
something she likes, how does
she pay for it?
Now we find that the last two
challenges here are entirely
within your application.
But they're large friction
points due to mobile forms and
other causes of pain that lead
to a high mobile cart
abandonments rate.
And that's what we tried to
solve with Google Wallet
Instant Buy.
As announced earlier today,
Google Wallet Instant Buy is a
small library that's part
of Google Play services,
available on every device
with the Play Store.
Now this means that a user with
Google Wallet can make
faster checkouts of physical
goods and services in only a
few taps on their phone.
Further, as a merchant, the
integration is very
lightweight.
Google Wallet sends your
application a usable proxy
card, complete with expiration
date, CVC, building address,
as well the shipping address
that the user would like those
items sent.
Because we're using a virtual
proxy card, the user is secure
in knowing that their physical
real data cards
are not being sent.
And further, it's free for
merchants and consumers.
So it's great.
So in creating the Google Wallet
Instant Buy app, we
focused on three major areas of
concern for users, in hopes
to avoid mobile cart
app abandonment.
And we'd like to share some of
our techniques and tips and
tricks that we've learned with
you and ways that you can
improve your own applications.
We focused on mobile-friendly
forms, reducing latency, and
improving security and privacy
for our users.
So how many of you have ever
been in an application, you've
added items to your shopping
cart, you go to check out and
have seen very lengthy forms
asking you to sign up, asking
for credit card information
and shipping information?
And you see these forms,
and have you ever said,
I don't have time?
I'm on the go.
I'm using an Android
tablet or a phone.
I just can't do it.
And so you bailed on
the transaction.
So we tried to focus on
making the interaction
as smooth as possible.
And while returning Wallet users
will be able to complete
a checkout process on your
application in two to three
taps, new Wallet users will
experience a signup flow.
So we've tried to optimize that
as much as possible using
mobile-friendly forms.
Let's show how that's done.
So I'm a new user using
Google Wallet.
And I'll say, Buy with
And as I'm a new user, Google
Wallet's going to ask me for
some information.
So the first piece is the
credit card number.
So I'll get out my credit card,
and I'll start typing.
And as we type, we see that
we're doing real time
formatting of the card number,
so if I were to make a
mistake, I could correct it
very easily, because I'm
following along as I go.
And when I do make a mistake, we
alert the user right away,
using simple client-side checks
and algorithm, known as
the loon algorithm, that
the card is invalid.
So I, as the user, can now
correct this card while the
card is still out on the table
and it's still fresh in my
mind what I'm doing.
So I'll go back, and I'll
correct the card.
It's a little hard to see on the
screen, but we were able
to auto advance from the credit
card field to the
expiration month, because we
knew that the user has
completed the credit card.
This allows me to simply follow
along with the credit
card data that I see and
continue my form.
Now by auto advancing from field
to field, we reduce the
need for the user from having
to find the next key, or
worse, hiding the keyboard,
scrolling to the next field
manually, and tapping into it.
And again, this is just to ease
user friction and help
users get through
the form faster.
So now I'll fill out my
name and continue.
And now we're at the always
troubling billing address.
Now addresses differ from credit
cards, in that they're
well known to the user, myself,
but they are difficult
to type out.
There's many fields, they come
in various forms, and they
switch from letters and
numbers all the time.
So we've integrated this logic
to be able to provide very
fast help by using the Places
API from Google Maps.
So right now we're
at 747 Howard
Street, here in San Francisco.
If you're typing 747 and the
letter H, we see that our
first result is where and our
required billing address.
So rather than type all
those details out, I
can select the address.
It fills out the form for me,
and I can continue on.
We don't have an apartment
or suite, so
I'll just scroll down.
For phone number, this device
does not have a cell network,
so there's no phone
number tied to it.
If it did, we could
prefill that.
So we'll just fill it in.
And I want to use this as my
shipping address, and I want
to use Google Wallet
to pay for future
purchases on this merchant.
So I'll continue.
Now in just that time, we have
signed up for Google Wallet
and continued through our
checkout process, saving the
user time now and later.
So let's show how we did
some of these features.
The first was our ability
to auto advance
from field to field.
To do that with our credit card,
we needed to know when
the credit card was complete
and also when it was valid.
So here's a very simple
implementation of this
interface for credit cards.
We'll say that a credit
card is complete if it
has at least 15 digits.
And we'll say that a credit card
is valid if it passes our
loon algorithm.
And now if it's valid, we want
to clear any errors on the
text field and return true.
If it's not valid, we want to
mark an error on the text
field for user action
and return false.
So how do we tie this into
our application?
For every field we want to
enable auto advance, we first
add a text watcher so that every
time the text changes we
can perform three actions.
The first is we ask
our validator,
is the field complete?
Does it have the correct
number of digits or
characters?
If so, we then ask
our validator to
validate that field.
If it's valid, we then use that
Android native library to
find the next focusable
element and
request focus on it.
So now let's turn to
the address fields.
By combining with various data
sources, we're able to provide
suggestions to the user on ways
they can complete that
address form as fast
as possible.
But we wanted to optimize
it, so we have
multiple data sources.
We use the Google Wallet
previous data as well as
Places API.
Now with any autosuggestion
feature with multiple data
sources, you want to strike
a balance between the most
relevant data to the user and
the data that is fastest to
acquire and show.
And in our case, previous Wallet
data meets both of
these criteria.
If you're a returning Wallet
user entering a new credit
card, for example, there's a
good chance that your billing
address will be the same as
your previous credit card.
And so like querying this data
locally and memory using
simple string comparisons, we
can determine if you're typing
the same address.
If not, or if you're a new
Wallet user, we'll then go to
the Places API.
This data is very rich.
However, it is not as personal,
in that it doesn't
include things like apartment
or a suite number.
Further, it requires a network
I/O and a round trip, so it's
not as fast as doing local
onboard memory.
So let's see some
code for this.
So a lot of autosuggestion
is really done within the
AutoCompleteTextView.
And this is a subclass of the
EditText component within
Android that has been a
part of the library
since Version 1.
The AutoCompleteTextView
component handles a lot of the
logistics and pain that's
caused by providing
autosuggestion results, leaving
the developer with two
simple operations.
The first is to provide the
results for a given query
using the perform filtering
method, which is run in a
background thread, so you're
able to do longstanding
operations, like fetching
data from the
network, disk, et cetera.
When you have the data, you then
need to tell the adapter
and the TextView that that
data is available.
And you do that from the
published results.
This notifies the TextView that
it needs to re-render the
drop-down with the appropriate
selections.
So we tried here to make the
form as easy and friendly to
fill out so that a user
could get through it
as quickly as possible.
Now with more on how to make
your applications faster and
more secure, I'll turn to Jon.
JON BOEKENOOGEN: Thank
you, John.
I want to start off by asking,
how many of you have used a
commerce application and
encountered a loading screen
that took a very long
time to complete?
And how many of you, after
encountering that loading
screen, either exited out of
the application or never
completed your transaction?
A lot of you.
As you look around the room,
you can see that this is a
major contributing factor
to today's mobile cart
abandonment rate.
And today, I'm going to provide
some tips on how to
make a good first impression
on your users and how to
improve the responsiveness of
your application once a user
has launched it.
125 milliseconds.
That is the time it takes from
when Instant Buy is launched
to when the user can
interact with it.
There's no loading dialogue.
A user can select a
shipping address.
They can select a credit card.
They can complete their
transaction.
We accomplish this by using
a technique known
as On Device Caching.
What you do here is you look for
that data you're going to
display on your first activity,
store it on the
device before your activity is
launched, so that way, the
next time your activity is
launched, you can populate the
UI from disk and provide a very
responsive experience for
your users.
Our team has found that caching
data that changes
infrequently is very good for
this technique, since it has a
low synchronization
requirements.
And more specifically, we use
it for loading our chooser
dialogue with shipping addresses
and mass credit card
info that's shown when we
launch Instant Buy.
However, there are some
challenges that come up with
this technique.
You need to know where you're
going to store this
information on the device,
how often you're going to
synchronize data from the Cloud
to the device, and how
to handle any cache
inconsistencies that may occur.
With storage, if you're going
to store any sensitive
information about the user or
your application, you need to
make sure that only your
app can read and
write to this file.
A popular place that people
like to store info on the
device is the SD card, due
to its large capacity.
But any app on the device can
read and write to the SD card
with the appropriate
permission.
So you shouldn't put sensitive
info there.
Once you start synchronizing
data from the Cloud to your
device, you need to be able to
handle any merge conflicts
that may come up.
Think about how this is going
to impact your user's
experience, if you're going to
provide any messaging about
what's going on.
And then with synchronization,
the frequency that you
synchronize data from the Cloud
to the device really
depends on your application and
the freshness of data that
your app requires.
But you should consider how this
synchronization strategy
will impact your user's
battery life and
their network usage.
These are limited resources on
any smartphone or tablet.
And if you abuse them, a
user may uninstall your
application.
So now I'm going to dive into
an example of a cache for
shipping addresses using
Shared Preferences.
Here I've created an address
store class.
In the Constructor, we're
grabbing a handle to Shared
Preferences.
We're specifying Context
Mode, Private.
Since shipping addresses are
sensitive information about a
user, this makes sure that only
my app can read and write
to this file.
Next, we have the getAddresses
method.
This'll simply convert from
the strings in Shared
Preferences to address
objects.
Finally, we have the
writeAddresses method, which
will convert a list of addresses
to strings to store
in Shared Preferences.
Here I'm using the compatibility
library for
performing the write.
So on newer versions
of Android,
it'll be more efficient.
So that's how to make
a good first
impression on your users.
Now let's make a lasting one.
So for this, we use the
technique we call prefetching
or precomputing data.
What you do here is you should
look for instances in your
application where you perform
an expensive operation after
an event or a user action,
such as a button click.
Try and move these up
earlier in the flow.
Perform them asynchronously once
you know all the inputs.
So that way, when that event is
fired, you can return the
result immediately.
Our team specifically
uses this for
prefetching auth tokens.
So that way, when a user clicks
the Submit button on
the bottom of the form, we can
just call the Wallet servers,
rather than having to fetch the
auth token and then call
the Wallet servers.
And after doing this, we
were able to reduce
our latency by 30%.
Again, there are some
challenges with this technique.
You shouldn't be using this for
any requests that modify
state about the user, such as
adding a shipping address.
These types of operations make
modifications on data that is
near and dear to the user.
And doing it without their
explicit consent or button
click is not within their
expectations.
And second, a further
optimization you can perform
with this technique
is what we call
handling the pending state.
Imagine you fire off a prefetch
request, and then
that event that requires the
response is triggered while
that request is ongoing.
Rather than firing a duplicate
request and starting over from
scratch, you should wait till
the prefetch request completes
and return that result.
This will further reduce the
loading dialogue in this case.
So now I'm going to jump into
an example of actually
prefetching an auth token
for a Google server.
Here I've defined the prefetch
auth token method.
We're going to kick
off an AsyncTask.
Call off to GoogleAuthUtil to
actually fetch the token.
This'll store the token on disk,
so future calls will
read from disk rather than
hitting the network.
For those that are wondering,
GoogleAuthUtil is also part of
Google Play services and could
be used for fetching tokens
for things like App Engine.
After that, we need to hook
up the prefetch auth token
method, after our
UI's displayed.
And finally, we need
to use that token.
Here we're doing it in
anonClickHandler.
We're going to fire off
another AsyncTask.
Read the token.
This time, it should
come from disk.
And we're going to
call our server.
Now some of you may notice that
I don't have the Pending
state being handled
on this slide.
And it was just too
much to fit.
I will be sending out a full
working example with the deck.
So now I'm going to jump into
some security and privacy
techniques that you can use
in your application.
Security and privacy is one of
those unseen user experience
features of any commerce
application.
And I'm going to provide some
quick tips to make sure that
you are handling your user's
information more safely and
how to maintain that trusting
relationship with your users.
So first and foremost, if you're
sending any sensitive
information about your
user or your
application to a remote server--
this is something that
all of you commerce
developers should be doing--
you need to make sure
that it's encrypted.
And we suggest HTTPS for this.
If you don't do this, a
malicious software or a
malicious user could view this
data over the network and
perform fraudulent activities.
Another thing you should
consider is data that you're
sending to Logcat.
On pre-Jelly-Bean devices, any
app on the phone can read any
other app's logs, as long as
they have the get logs'
permission.
From there, they can send these
logs to a remote server,
parse out pieces that they're
interested in, and
do what they want.
So our team uses Proguard
to not only optimize our
application but also
strip logging.
And the reason we chose Proguard
is it doesn't require
any code modifications and can
easily be done on release
builds before uploading
to the Play Store.
This comes in two steps.
First, you need to enable
Proguard optimizations for
your application.
This is done by adding
this one line to your
project.properties file.
And second, you need to tell
Projuard which method calls to
remove from your app.
Here we're removing
android.util.log i, v, and d.
And this is done by using this
assumenosideeffects clause.
When paired with Proguard
optimizations, Proguard will
treat these method calls as
NoOps and completely remove
them from your app.
So that concludes some of the
tips that the Instant Buy team
used for improving our users'
experience and their safety.
I'm going to hand it off to
Haisoo from The Fancy, and
he's going to tell you how
they wowed their users.
HAISOO SHIN: Thank you.
So The Fancy is the place to
discover and collect from a
Cloud-created catalog of unique
and amazing things.
Here you will find all these
beautiful gadgets, fashion
items, traveling spots, and many
more, and you can fancy
anything you like.
And when you find something you
like, you'll want to buy
and own them as well.
So at Fancy, whether a $5
keyring, $3,000 watch, or even
$3 million helicopter, you can
buy them right inside our app.
So my focus is to provide a
frictionless experience from
signup to checkout.
And the Google API has really
helped us achieve that on
Android platform.
So I'm going to dive right
into demo and show
you how we did it.
Let's start with signin.
So this is the first
screen you see when
you launch our app.
I'm going to show you how Google
Signin works and press
that button.
So we were one of the
[INAUDIBLE] to partner to
implement this, and the adoption
has been so much
faster than expected.
One of the reasons must be this
screen, which you see
right there.
Because here you can see exactly
what information of
you we will have access to.
And I'm just going
to press OK here.
But you can actually fine-tune
all these privacy settings and
really control your data.
So you can see how this is great
for users who are more
sensitive about their privacy.
Now you're signed in.
So as you can see,
it's fast, easy.
It's very transparent.
And it has all the cool
features, like this morning at
the keynote, over at the
[INAUDIBLE] store and
cross-platform authentication.
And finally, users just
tend to trust Google.
So it's a great way
to reduce friction
from your signup process.
And it also plays well
with Google Wallet.
So let's see if there's anything
I might want to buy.
Everything looks great.
This one looks particularly
good.
So I'm just going to open
up the item page.
And one of the exciting features
we have introduced
together with Google Wallet is
this Buy Now button you see at
the item page.
As the name suggests, it'll
skip all the intermediate
steps, like the Cart page,
and goes right
into the payment flow.
So I'll show you how it works.
Press this button.
And very quickly you will be
prompted with this Google
Wallet dialog.
Where your information is
already filled out from other
services or Google services.
And notice that there's this
little checkbox there.
And what this does is you're
saying you approve to use
Google Wallet at Fancy
for future purchases.
So you won't see this
dialog again when
you buy from us again.
I'm just going to
press Continue.
And you're already at the last
stage where you can see the
final process and you
can press Complete.
And now you're done.
So as you can see, from the item
page where I decided to
buy this, I only needed
to tap three times to
complete the purchase.
And next time, it'll
be only two taps.
So that's very amazing.
And the whole Buy Now button
really works for us, because
we have a great deal of
single-item orders, especially
on Android.
So we believe this will
be a major way for our
users to buy from us.
And we are very excited.
Now that I just bought something
very cool, I want to
brag about it to my friends
and family.
So I'm going to share
it on Google+.
So this is the kind of
opportunity you want to take
advantage of to promote
your app and create
some word of mouth.
And Google+ Interactive
Posts is really the
right tool for this.
I'm just going to share it right
there and go back to the
slide and show how that looks.
So every Interactive Post, they
have something called a
Call to Action button.
In this case, it's
a buy button.
You can name it from the long
list of button labels.
And when you click this, it'll
actually then link it to our
app and opens up the relevant
page, in this
case the item page.
If you do not have our app
installed already, then you'll
be taken to Google Play Store
page, where you can install
it, launch it.
And you can sign in,
and you'll still be
taken to the item page.
And remember, this button is
coming from your friends and
family, so this is a very
personal and effective way to
promote your app.
And we are seeing very
[INAUDIBLE] rates of this
button on Android.
But the bigger picture I'm
trying to show you through
this demo is that with this tool
you can achieve a viral
cycle where discovery converts
into purchase with minimum
friction, and purchase brings
in more discoveries.
Now we are going to share some
other tips we have learned
from our own experience
at Fancy.
We have a very international
user base.
We have orders from all
over the world.
And here are some of the things
you might want to
consider for your international
users.
So most of you must be used to
the form where the country is
placed at the left after
the state box.
But really, you want to reverse
them, because state
box actually depends
on the country.
So if you have United States
selected, it will be a usual
dropbox with state.
And if it's Canada, you'll be
prompted with a dropbox with a
list of provinces.
For some other countries, maybe
you want to fall back to
a plain textbox, which
can be optional.
And postal code,
it looks easy.
But I made the mistake
of assuming
they are always numbers.
And I made our postal code
box number only.
And it turns out some countries,
like the United
Kingdom or Canada, they
also use letters.
So I actually prevented some
users from placing
an order from us.
So you do not want to make
the same mistake.
Now you, of course, want to
localize your app for your
international users.
But you have to remember, once
you do that, people will start
to enter their addresses
in their own languages.
So make sure your apps, your
backend codes, and even your
logistic teams are ready
to handle that.
Finally, we found out it's a
very good idea to predict the
user's country and present
that as a default.
It sounds minor and trivial,
but it's not just about
eliminating the pain to go
through hundreds of countries
just to find your own.
But it's also about sending out
the message that you are
able to handle their
orders correctly.
Because when I buy something
internationally, I tend to be
cautious, and I get worried.
Do they even ship
to my country?
Or what about the import tax?
Stuff like that.
But when I see my country
selected when I open up the
form, it gives me a certain
degree of confidence.
So there are a couple
of ways to do that.
The most accurate and fastest
way to do it is pull it from
the carrier using this class
called TelephonyManager.
It's accurate and fast, but
it's not always available.
A few carriers or Wi-Fi-only
devices, you wouldn't have
this information available.
So make sure your fall back to
the Local settings, which is
linked to your Languages
setting, so it'll won't be
always accurate.
But it's always available, so
you can fall back to that.
If your app happens to be using
the user's location info
for some other reason, you
could also use that.
And you could also do
the GeoIP lookup.
So now that on the mobile
environment you know that even
a single button click can cause
a significant latency
and friction, you want to avoid
that as much as you can
by predicting what a user
is going to do early.
One obvious example is payment
and shipping address, because
you know they will use the
same one in most cases.
So you can precalculate tax and
shipping and show that at
an early stage, like
the Cart page.
And you can let them pay with
their last credit card without
going through additional steps,
like the Payment page.
Of course, they should be
presented with a chance to
change it at some point
during the process.
But my point here is that you do
not want to make your users
move their finger just to do
something you can anticipate.
That's it from me.
And I'll hand the stage
back to John.
JOHN STUPPY: Thank
you, Haisoo.
We were very excited to work
with Fancy on integrating
Instant Buy into their
application.
It's available today on the Play
Store, and I encourage
you to check it out.
It's very cool.
There are some very unique
items on there.
So let's wrap up.
Today we discussed how using
Google Wallet Instant Buy can
improve conversion on your
site by eliminating or
reducing a lot of the pain
that users experience in
checking out of payment
applications.
We leveraged a lot of cool
mobile-friendly form
technology, such as real time
formatting, instant
validation, auto advancing
form fields, and input
suggestions.
And these are things that
you can do in your own
applications as well.
Further, we mentioned how
on device caching and
precomputing and fetching data
before it's needed can help
with that first impression on
the user's mind as well as
their lasting impression as
they use your app and
learn to love it.
We also stressed how handling
user data safely is a very
large concern, because it
instills a degree of trust in
your users that encourages
them to buy with your
applications.
Haisoo mentioned how leveraging
the Google+ Sign In
has helped Fancy with Android
developers, signing them into
the application and getting
them started.
He also mentioned a number of
international tips that you
should be aware of to be
more accessible in
international markets.
So where can you go from here?
You can sign up for
Instant Buy at
getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com.
There will be an Instant Buy
Code Lab on Friday at 9:00 AM
with our colleagues, in which
you'll go through the
integration process of
Instant Buy into a
sample merchant app.
Also, there will be Wallet
office hours and a Developer
Sandbox on the second floor.
In addition, Fancy will be at
the Google+ Developer Sandbox,
also located on the
second floor.
And again, I encourage you to
check out Fancy with Instant
Buy on the Play Store,
available today.
So thank you very much.
I'll now invite our Product
Manager up, Prakash, to help
answer some questions.
Are there any questions?
JON BOEKENOOGEN: Please
go to the mic.
JOHN STUPPY: Oh, and
please go to the
mic, if you have questions.
We've got one.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering
if this works on the
mobile web at all?
Is this strictly--
JOHN STUPPY: So does this
work on mobile web?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Yeah.
So we have a similar solution
which has been public.
You can go to our
Developer page.
And essentially, we have
Instant Buy for
mobile web and apps.
What we announced today was
Instant Buy for mobile apps.
Instant Buy for mobile web has
been live since last fall.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We're always having to be
cognizant of accessibility.
And I was wondering, with your
auto advancing features, how
does that play with
accessibility?
JOHN STUPPY: So how does auto
advancing play with
accessibility?
Can you go to Prakash
on this one?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: OK.
So basically, with the auto
advancement, because it's very
intuitive, it's less input
required by the user.
It basically guides our user
to a flow, so it helps with
the accessibility challenge,
if you will.
AUDIENCE: Does it announce the
fields as you march through
them or allow you to read back
what you've entered?
I can't see.
And so I've just entered a
credit card number, and I need
to be able to validate it.
Validation errors,
do they get read?
I'm just wondering if that's
something that you have to
roll yourself or
how that works.
JON BOEKENOOGEN: Yes.
As it progresses through the
form, it will read out the
description of what the field
is based on the hint text.
And if there's an error that
comes up, it will also speak
what the error is.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
JON BOEKENOOGEN: Any
other questions?
All right.
JOHN STUPPY: Great.
JON BOEKENOOGEN: Well, thank
you all for coming.